what makes men behave violently towards
their partner you saw dr. Julia Shore
the criminal psychologist and author who
features in that series she joins me now
here in the studio hi thanks for joining
us doctor appreciate it women are more
vulnerable in their own homes than
anywhere else yeah I think we have this
mystified idea of the murderer as the
stranger as sort of someone in a dark
alley who's lurking he's maybe a
psychopath but actually it's most often
a loved one who especially and as an
escalation of domestic violence commits
murder especially a woman why two men
kill their partners I think usually it
has to do when we look at mmm when we
look at the evidence as to what people
cite as the reasons one of the main ones
is jealousy another one is this idea
that it's either a former partner a
partner who the person is concerned will
leave them with the idea being that if I
can't have her nobody can which is very
different from the way women often
respond to these kinds of situations
because intimate partner violence is
less likely to be perpetrated by a woman
of course there are still situations but
it's much less likely and certainly into
a partner homicide is much less likely
for women so it's about control I think
a lot of it is about thinking that women
are I mean in a basic sense objects to
be owned and I think that is still a
deeply gray mentality that sort of woman
belongs to men and so if again this idea
that if if she's not mine then she's
this she's an object I can destroyed
rather destroy her than share her with
somebody else can you spot a killer
before they commit a crime I mean there
are some warning signs when we look at
domestic violence oh I mean domestic
violence and rape actually not actually
fantasies as much more myths so
endorsing certain kinds of myths around
again sort of ownership around believing
that women are asking for trouble victim
blaming those kinds of things those we
know are risk factors for engaging in
violence towards women but I think
overall we'd be surprised by who's
capable I mean it is mostly those who we
love the most who are capable of these
kinds of things and I think overall we
need to stop demonizing the idea of
murder I think everyone is probably
capable of murder given the wrong car
right contacts if you will and I think
that we need to stop pretending it's
sort of an us-versus-them it's us the
good people and them the evil people
them the purple people who are capable
of murder so for me that that sort of
idea of evil I think really needs to be
broken down so that we can better
understand these issues yeah are you mad
or bad I mean we often hear that come
comparison don't we what's your view on
that
there's matter bad but then there's also
matter bed and then there's me I mean
where we almost always I think consider
ourselves outside of this category and I
mean this is even true for people who
have offended who are in prison for
example that I mean we all have our own
rationale we have our reasons we
understand the nuances of our behavior
and so we still say no but I I was
justified or maybe I regret it but
that's not me and my entirety I'm still
a human being
I'm still mostly not that not bad or mad
whether mental health issues contribute
to these kinds of issues I think that
link is generally overstated again there
is a small overlap especially with
things relate to substance abuse so if
you're self-medicating for things like
depression with things like using
illicit substances you're more likely to
gauge a violent behavior but overall
mental health issues are almost never
connected with risk for violence are we
more tolerant of women that commits
murder as potentially a crime of passion
as opposed to men probably I mean it is
comparatively rare so I think the
circumstances that lead to a woman
murdering someone are generally going to
be more extreme and perhaps also more
understandable so I think again things
like domestic violence often also
precedes so there's almost the other way
around so it's not the woman is acting
in a violent way towards her husband or
partner repeatedly it's more often that
the partner is actually engaging in a
domestic violence against the woman and
the woman basically fights back which i
think is it's easier I think to
empathize with that kind of situation
even though of course it's a completely
inappropriate response that kind of
situation when we see I mean domestic
violence isn't necessarily a private
matter is it because when you look at I
don't know Ted Bundy or whatever in the
number of people that he has murdered
and allegedly murdered when you look
back at his lifestyle and
there would have been violence in his
background ah this is a I I really I
think we need to be very careful not to
look back at the past of people who we
know as adults of committed crimes and
to say to basically blame their pasts
and blame their upbringing and to the
way that I sometimes say it don't just
blame their mom
I mean we're back to sort of blaming the
woman in a man's life to have sort of
ruined him which i think is a just it's
sooo totally oversimplifying a really
complex issue
so I mean certainly people who engage in
most kinds of offending behavior are
more likely to be from impoverished
upbringings they're more likely to come
from low socioeconomic status however
there are of course many exceptions and
of course having low socioeconomic
status doesn't mean that you're going to
become an offender so it's I think a lot
of people grew up with terrible
circumstances and turned out fine and a
lot of people grew up in great
circumstances and turned out not fine so
I think that that they now make I would
caution us to look back and say that's
why because it's always going to be
confluence of factors is there anything
that women can do to make themselves
safer at home when they potentially well
from what you're saying you don't
necessarily know that that's what's
going to happen that that your partner
is going to come along and feel that
they you can be destroyed if they can't
have you no one can yeah of course I
mean generally we would presumably not
put ourselves in those kind of
situations and that's also why of course
intimate partner well partner murder
specifically is mostly committed by
people we trust
that's why we find ourselves in
situations where they're able to commit
those kinds of crimes to protect
ourselves I mean in in my book making
evil I actually talk about murder and I
talked about the banality of it some of
it is really been off some of it I think
you just can't see coming but other
things I mean if you are in a situation
for example where you're the victim of
intimate partner violence trying to seek
help try and seek resources now in an
age of budget cuts in an age of cutting
of funding to things like vermin woman's
refuges and of course cultural issues
around who's able to seek those kinds of
services and who's who feels able to I
think there's a lot of barriers that we
need to break down as
to actually offer proper support to
individuals who are frenum cells in
high-risk situations fascinating doctor
thank you so much for joining us we
really appreciate it thank you